so is the is the rapid acceleration of
change is that the biggest risk more
than the technology itself just the
ability for it to change so quickly and
evolve so quickly is that sort of
scarier to you than what we might come
up with I don't sense you're scared by
any of this actually but the the risk of
course of course
well yes I look I think what's happening
is we for example you know just even
talking about the elections Hillary and
Trump will are not addressing issues
that are happening here in the modern
world like artificial intelligence gene
editing designer babies huge things that
have already happened and that will
continue to happen they're still
addressing Social Security taxes foreign
policy just like they did for the last
50 years the problem is that nothing is
going to be as important to Social
Security as this this anti aging or this
longevity movement that's underfoot
right now I mean when everyone lives 150
years you can just throw out your Social
Security and that hundred fifty years is
already happening we might only be a few
years from reversing or stop being aging
through genetic editing so the questions
that they're asking and the questions
that they're lete the media's leading
the country to ask I think is a lot of
times backwards mm-hmm you know things
are changing much quicker than before
and we need to learn to adjust to those
changes and so far nobody especially the
top people in the government are
adjusting to us yeah you know it's
interesting I read a book called 2030 by
Albert Brooks it was his fiction novel
about what he thinks America's gonna be
like in 2030 and one of the the issues
that he thinks we're gonna face the most
is that our aging population is going to
keep staying alive and because of that
the economic strain that it's gonna put
on young people is gonna cause not like
a racial war but like an age war because
the young people are gonna keep paying
into a system to keep older people alive
who aren't producing as much for society
and that's just one of the many that's
what popped into my head is you were
saying that just there's so many issues
we're focused on the same five things
you know the designer baby thing is
another one that's good because it's
like we're always focused on abortion
but there's a lot of other ethical
things that are
popping up whether we talk about him or
not of course of course and it you know
and all of them are interconnected
you know the abortion thing is classic
my wife is an ob/gyn at Planned
Parenthood so I'm you know directly
connected to a lot of that stuff and the
designer baby thing is so amazing
because we now you know there's a couple
universities around the world working on
artificial wombs and they've actually
been able to raise a you know kind of a
goat from a little embryo all the way to
basically almost being alive and we
basically probably have this technology
to do this with our children you know in
ten years time meaning that you can
bypass basically the human body almost
entirely and you don't need to have sex
and then there's other methods too you
can just take a shot and combine your
own DNA you know there's cloning
techniques so the whole world is
changing so dramatically and people are
still stuck on the concept of you know
whether you know you're pro-life or
pro-choice when just literally five to
ten years from now there's going to be a
huge amount of new technologies that not
necessarily make that question obsolete
but change that question so so
dramatically
you know effort for the pro-lifers if
you can preserve a life and you have
this ecto Genesis or this artificial
womb do you ask society you know do ask
somebody to give up the baby and then
raise it there even if it's only been
one week old then there's this other
idea that we can now keep you know it
used to be that the the limit was twenty
six weeks and that's when a baby could
survive you know outside the womb well
we're gonna get it down to so a baby can
survive in twelve weeks here in the next
couple years that changes again because
then you're like well where is that line
so technology is making the world crazy
in the you know I hopefully and
obviously in a good way but what's
happening is a lot of ethicists and a
lot of the government is not able to
keep up with up with how fast it's
changing right well even that example
that you gave is really great so if
you're against abortion and you wouldn't
want someone to have an abortion but but
let's say the woman wants to have the
abortion and if the technology exists to
keep that fetus alive you know two weeks
after insemination if that if something
exists well then is it the state's
responsibility to pay for that who has
it
so there are real-world it sounds like
sci-fi with
our real-world implications that are
that all be happening yeah right around
the corner and and you know probably
within ten years we're gonna be able to
keep you know a one you know month-old
or even any less of he just alive and
that's that's gonna be a very difficult
question I think for society face the
good news though is there's also gonna
come into technology like your phone
that can just scan or just take a blood
test and within minutes of having sex
tell you whether you're pregnant or not
or whether that's happening not minutes
but maybe within within twelve hours so
you'll have better and then probably be
other ways because the morning-after
pills to terminate it sort of like you
know just take vitamins or you know
something like that
making the whole system a bit easier so
there's a counterbalance because
obviously you know if technology goes to
one side then you know you know maybe
we'll have to actually revisit this
entire question as a society back to the
Supreme Court and the problem is though
technology changes so quickly that what
you know even the idea of having babies
inside a womb is going to become
something that I think is gonna be very
controversial there's you know let's be
honest them giving birth is is something
that's very medically dangerous
oftentimes involves major surgery if you
have a c-section what not and and you
know in evolving don't wanna get myself
into much but an evolving country an
evolving Society would try to make it so
that motherhood does not involve that
type of medical danger and that's where
you know the artificial wombs are gonna
come in it also means that women don't
have to take off all that time off work
and now we can kind of get back to the
Equal Pay area and say is that what
caused it or was a really discrimination
and built into the system i I think
there probably is but you know it would
be a way to solve it but what's most
interesting is again just going you know
thinking about transhumanism in the next
ten years all these things are going to
be changing because of all these
different types of technologies that we
have and rewriting what are our Father
you know what our parents taught us was
right or wrong and saying well the rules
have changed I mean the greatest example
that's happening right now is Mothers
Against Drunk Driving you know it's one
of the largest nonprofits in the country
you know I have two kids who wants her
to deal with any drunk drivers but
driverless cars will literally wipe out
this tragic prom that the whole world
has because nobody will be driving drunk
anymore and it's a great idea you know
for how a single technology has
eliminated a prom that is literally
killed hundreds and hundred millions of
Americans one yeah at this point at the
same point of course the counterbalance
would be that someone could hack into
the system of course for their profit he
could be drug unit for in front of a
computer right you know so yeah it gets
crazy so they're really I mean you
should mention the matrix before but it
really when you open up the Pandora's
box of this stuff the the sort of
offshoots that you can go to are really
endless it it is and I think what's very
interesting is and I hope this is one of
the the most difficult challenge I think
with with my candidacy and talking about
transhumanism is how do economics work
into it because what you what capitalism
is done is always like someone move
forward on this end well then someone
there was a competitor or some other
idea here and so there always was a
pretty good balance but as we move
forward I'm not sure like when everyone
loses their jobs do the robots and
whatnot
whether that balance will continue and
that's when it gets dangerous because so
far technology has been neutral and it's
been to people who have made it you know
bad or good or whatever in the future we
need to somehow maybe through regulation
or just maybe you know crossing our
fingers and hoping that that balance
continues and that technology and
science continue to make our lives
better but doesn't become some kind of
dystopia world and of course as all the
sci-fi ebooks point out right so it's
interesting because you're on one hand
you're describing yourself as a left
libertarian but you're acknowledging
that some regulation might be necessary
because we'll just sort of will evolve
ourselves out of the system at some
point if we don't do that you know so on
my I took a funny bus tour across the
country for four months on my campaign
and I'm intermittent you know I mingled
a lot with truck drivers because they
were all in the road and we were hanging
out with them quite often and think that
the truck stops and um you know they've
now had in Europe they had ten big giant
semi rigs try driverless across the
continent and America is only a couple
years away from having driverless trucks
we have about approximately 4 million
truck drivers these are grown men many
of them like
guns many of them would not be able to
get other jobs very easily because there
had been truck drivers for the last 20
or 30 years and they're gonna
potentially be replaced here in a few
years we're talking four million jobs
and grown men so what do you do with
that you can't just say oh we're gonna
give you welfare they probably wouldn't
settle for that these are these are men
that will say though I I got a gun don't
tell me what that do so we you know that
one of the things I'm trying to do at
the party with my campaign is establish
you know economic parameters that might
help people move into the new transhuman
stage you know either through universal
basic income there's a there can be a
libertarian version or you know or other
different means but whatever it is we
don't want to we don't want to the
government to become Big Brother but at
the same time we realize that we're not
sure capitalism can survive if we robots
start taking everyone's job right so in
that case you would be for a universal
basic income so that you it would really
just be a transition sort of for that
for some of these people that maybe
would just put their hands up and be
like the world's passing me by here so
let me survive well and the good thing
about a universal basic income which
which I do support but you know I
support a kind of a thinner one and it's
not one that says overnight I wanted to
happen I would it's got to be something
that's you know transition slowly so
that all the economies don't fall apart
but yes at some point I think we need to
consolidate welfare we need to
consolidate Obamacare we need to
consolidate Social Security you know
into one giant package that says even if
you're gonna because we have this other
issue that anyone that's born today is
almost certainly not gonna die or
there's going to be so many different
types of technologies out there that can
keep you alive and deftly I mean when
you look at the the a the life span age
its doubled in the last century and it's
gonna it's going to now it's going to
quadruple and the reality is that if
people live that long we need to do
something for them they need to have
something that they can feed themselves
house themselves you know be able to
live a life where they don't cause civil
strife and that's really my main worry
because for me I I don't really like the
idea of a universal basic income from a
humanitarian perspective
I think that's good but what I really
don't like is revolution or civil war
so that's more and for from a science
perspective the best thing to do is keep
peace so I would compromise it a nice
compromise as a universal basic income
yeah so is the inherent flaw of all this
that all of these technologies are going
to be accessible to two rich people or
wealthier people or people with more
means earlier and that ultimately and
poor people even with a universal vacant
basic income won't have access to the
stuff and we're gonna almost create like
a series of super humans and a series of
old-school non chip regular people and
it'll really be like your human
experience will be completely different
than probably more than 50% of the world
you know the question you just asked is
the question I get asked the most
because everybody works yeah I know it's
a great one but it's the one that
everyone worries about because everyone
knows people are not part of the 1% I'm
certainly not part of that 1% so I worry
about the question too and I I want to
make sure that the you know that 1%
doesn't take that technology and leave
me in the dust because it you know in
the same way we're seeing accelerating
technology to this Jaykar people
improving you know technology growing so
quickly people's access our people the
rich people's personal improvements
might actually skyrocket and you might
find like for example through gene
editing technology someone's child has
30 to 40% smarter than your child
because they had were able to afford the
augmentation technology well that's a
totally that's now society's unfair now
we're getting into you know brave new
world type of stuff so we need to as a
society come up with a plan or that one
percent doesn't leave us behind
it's not the same playing field it was
before right the world is changing too
quickly so even though I do what I want
to stay as a libertarian I understand
that if we don't do something different
it could explode in a in a bad way right
and I guess you could argue that that's
happening now anyway right because right
now if you're wealthy you can get your
children to the best doctors you can get
them to the best schools all of those
things I'm sure every metric there is
would show that they're gonna have a
better chance to succeed in life so
we're just adding the technological
component to it in this discussion but
this is stuff that's going on already
and in you're right I mean when you look
at how much longer rich people live than
poor people it's about 25 percent you
know and when you look at how much more
educated they are you know I mean the
facts speak for themselves so you know I
broadly would like to create a much more
a society which with much more equality
in it but I think the the issue right
now is that that's a that's a very
difficult thing to do under all the
circumstances you know there's just too
much right now inequality seems to be
growing technology seems to be
accentuating that and at some point
we're going to have to step in and say
wow the world is changing really quickly
we better take a long hard look at this
and you know one of the reasons we
actually like I delivered a
transhumanist bill of rights to the US
Capitol and one of the very most
important rights in it is that everybody
has a universal basic right to an
indefinite lifespan or access to
transhumanist technology because of this
very real concern that maybe only 10%
are gonna get it and that change would
be so much more dramatic than the 10%
even becoming wealthy I mean what if the
10% become 500% smarter genetically this
is we're no longer dealing with the same
species than practice yeah so we have to
be careful we don't go down that path I
mean if you think black lives matter
that you know is something that is
controversial well what are you talking
about when you say you know the 1% have
now become these gods practically I mean
that's something that I think is to be
far more controversial we can't let that
happen
so getting away from the human side of
this or the individual side of this I
think there's an interesting piece of
this that's Nation related are there any
countries right now that are doing a
better job at this stuff that are really
looking at the future of this stuff and
the ethics and all the things we're
discussing better than the United States
right now I suspect we're not doing it
particularly well well I mean we have
you have to kind of go back to what
happened with George W Bush and his you
know essentially 1652 17 years ago stem
cell technology was one of the most
important technology and it still is of
the 21st century and it's it's doing
wonders right now for replacing you know
giving people mobility back that have
been in accidents and paraplegics and
whatnot
and other types of treatments too but he
created this atmosphere where when he
shut down federal funding for stem cells
literally for seven years during his two
terms they were set a precedent that was
very auntie transhumanist and the
bioethicists that he had in the White
House were very anti radical technology
can you explain for people that have no
knowledge of this whole thing why what
the ethical argument was over that sure
sure well you know a stem cell basically
essentially came from aborted fetuses
originally yeah and that was weed and
then they were taking stem cell
technologies and stem cells are
essentially original cells in your body
that can become any different type of
cells but the promise in the very
beginning we were getting those stem
cells from aborted fetus tissue and that
was very controversial to the
Republicans and of course since we had a
Republican in office he said no the
federal government is not going to
support stems you know research on stem
cell technology and then what happened
is Obama came into office and said
listen stem cell technology is not about
abortion or anything like that it's
about helping people and helping
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
people which is now happened so obama
reversed the stem cell you know issue
that george w bush had put in and now
there's been all this funding going into
it and all sun stem cell technologies
back is one of the the great 21st
century treatments but the problem was
that it said you know what george w bush
did set a precedent kind of what all the
trans tumor surrounds say that was the
very first anti transhumanist government
thing that stood in the way of our
health because a lot of people think
stem cells might even be used for
something like art disease or for it is
being used for our disease or for cancer
treatment meaning it can be a life
extension technology we can live longer
so if a president steps in and says you
can't do that he's also saying we're not
interested in you living longer
we have ethical frameworks that we have
to work around and that's when
transhumance were like whoa this the
government has gone too far and this is
why it's very important that the
bioethicists that are in the white house
are supporting the president that are
supporting the government are for
technology and science you know you can
have a scientist who doesn't love
science and
me that that doesn't help the human race
that's not good so every week on this
show for one reason or another I say
that the road to hell is paved with good
intentions so in a case like this I
would suspect that george w bush's
decision-making was that he was looking
out for for the unborn child so i don't
think his intentions were malicious
however the result of his intentions
were to go against what science can
allow us to do and i guess the bigger
issue really is that if he had if they
had stopped it completely you know no
government funding and we're gonna
prosecute you if we find out that you're
doing this on your own
someone's still gonna do it so it
doesn't in a way that would make it more
dangerous because then you'd have only
people doing it outside of the system of
course of course and so this is just
setting up you know you the question you
necessarily this is exactly what sort of
happened and I agree with you I don't
think george w bush of course wanted to
end lies earlier i mean he really just
was trying to you know follow the wishes
of his party and protect the unborn
child so i I know that but what happens
is that it becomes a national issue and
the end result for many people including
myself was that my life and the health
care system is less because of it but I
think what's happened now is this sets a
precedent for genetic editing which is
sort of the next stem cell the next war
that the governments are fighting sort
of with scientists right now genetic
editing the CRISPR case 9 technology
allows you to sort of take your genetic
nature and and structured almost like
you would software code you can put in
different pieces so we're able to create
animals that have much heavier muscles I
have friends that are already starting
to look into trying to grow a third eye
on the back of their head well I didn't
have a lucious evolution give us a third
eye I mean it sounds crazy but that's
something that we can start to think
about with CRISPR technology it's
probably 10 or 15 years out but it's
something that we're gonna be able to
the idea of growing a another set of
arms is now a hundred percent possible
because of this gene editing technology
now you can see that's very very
controversial wow you want four arms
well how does that work and you know if
you're in the Olympics is that something
different right I mean this is island of
dr. Moreau of course of course
so China about a year and a half ago you
know started working on the very first
embryo and modifying it with this
genetic technology it sent the the
medical community into shockwaves
oh my god they're they're you know
they're doing creating monsters this and
that so immediately a bunch of
moratoriums were you know argued what
they people were arguing to put a
moratorium on the technology and luckily
that didn't exactly happen but the
American government has stepped in and
now they're considering the issue
luckily there's actually been pockets of
CRISPR technology that have now been
approved you know at least with some
government consent to move forward
because it's it's a technology that
potentially can eliminate every single
disease as well as do all sorts of other
amazing things you know the one that you
hear a lot about with CRISPR
technologies should we eradicate the
mosquito by creating a mosquito that
doesn't have malaria and that brings
with others and then no mosquitoes will
ever have malaria that's that's what
CRISPR can do right wouldn't miss them
lead to Jurassic world we create a
dinosaur that's better than every other
dinosaur and then it destroys the park
and that's that's where the ethical
quandary is and that's why nobody is
really sure now I may not be super
supportive of AI technology because I
worry about it but I am hundred percent
support of a CRISPR I think as long we
you know in the transformers community
we have this thing called morphological
freedom it's pretty pretty much the most
important fundamental right
morphological freedom means the right to
do anything with your body so long as it
doesn't hurt somebody else and that
means growing a second head as
controversial as that is that's what it
means it also means you know the ability
to change yourself gender-wise anything
you want to do you you should be able to
do it if you can do it through that way
it's a hundred percent okay and most
trans to miss believe in I strongly
believe in that I think what's gonna
happen in the future is America and
society as a whole is gonna have to
grapple with this new civil rights era
of people using this genetic technology
to change themselves so dramatically I
mean you talk about skin color we're
talking about trans humans are talking
about the bar on tap new tattoo newly in
Star Wars yeah I mean we're talking
about very different species that's what
some of my friends are trying to do when
they're using this technology
I have friends right now that are trying
to splice in plant DNA into their skin
with the with the CRISPR so that they
can photosynthesize
from the Sun so they no longer have to
eat food that's how dramatic this CRISPR
can go and you could solve world hunger
that way too yeah
wait so people are actually testing this
stuff on themselves which i think is
kind of fascinating so you have the chip
in you but you you weren't testing it on
yourself you knew it was a proven
technology well basically a proven
technology the time right yes although
the chipping thing is very controversial
it's not FDA approved or anything like
that it's it's just it's and in some
states it can also be illegal depending
on how its administered because you
actually have to get someone to put it
in you but those things aside the chips
not a very big deal but there came out
last year a DIY CRISPR kit for around a
hundred dollars that you can mess with
and start taking apart your own genes
and mixing it with other genes and then
putting it back inside you and see if
anything happened now it's very
rudimentary that doesn't work it sounds
incredibly dangerous I mean I'm on board
every course I do but of course and this
is why they're so controversial
now most these people have no idea what
they're doing right and they're just
they're they're I don't want say they're
amateurs but they're citizen scientists
but there are some with you know that at
universities doing the exact same thing
on a much bigger level I mean CRISPR was
basically born out of MIT and that's
they're the people that are literally
gonna be changing the world and like I
said it's been funny even the Wall
Street Journal I think New York Times
everybody was caught was running the
controversy about using CRISPR to
eliminate malaria because here we've had
Bill Gates you know spend so much money
on you know thankfully trying to
eliminate malaria kills about 750,000
people every year and we might have a
chance to literally eliminate it
entirely through this type of technology
but should we do it what if we eliminate
the mosquito and all sudden
half the populations fall apart because
you know it's like introducing rabbits
somewhere we don't know really what
happens but at least it's got the
country talking about it and it's got it
talking about not the third arm I think
the third arm like I talked about is a
bit weird but the mosquito is a good way
to approach this radical technology that
you can literally alter the genetic
structure of a species to make it so
that it's more friendly for humans so
these people that they so they buy the
kit and they go all right I'm gonna get
some photosynthesis going on my arm so
that the Sun will re-energize or the
will i reaiize me well it'll feed me
essentially yeah yes okay so the sun's
gonna be I mean this sounds like the
beginning of a Marvel comic book right
where the guy then turns into a tree and
you know three man is of course you know
of course and we're entering that age I
think what's so I mean you know it gets
it gets really even weirder uh you know
I've even heard of a person trying to
grow a second penis for example I mean
it can go really crazy what people want
to do and and I think though was that
the problem really - when you combine
this with politics that someone would
watch let's say you were polling at ten
percent right now right like it was
actually making a dent in that way the
takeaway from this interview would be
someone would get you saying second
penis that would be the queen and then
they would go see he'd see some kook
scientist blob you know saying all this
crazy stuff and that is sort of the the
big flaw of all this trying to combine
cutting-edge science with our antiquated
political and media I know and if I do
this again in 2020 and I and I'm for a
bigger party and I have a better shot at
it I won't be saying things like that I
have interview but no you know but I
think we have to take a bigger step I
think in four years this technology
we're talking about it's not going to be
some far-out science fiction thing it's
gonna be something everybody's already
heard of we're already going to be using
CRISPR technology to cure cancer we
already have cured some cancers or at
least with some people with it because
you can go into their genetic structure
and change things that's it's just like
coding and I think at some point people
may have to grow up with how fast
technology is changing around America
and not say oh I'm taking a sound bite
just so I can sell ads for CNN or Fox or
whatever and I'm gonna actually hear
what this person has to say because if
they did they'd say wow this guy doesn't
want to do that you know but what he's
saying is isn't amazing what we can
actually do with it with this new
technology and the thing is whether they
like it or believe in it or not it's
happening so yeah
you either get on the train or and it's
happening so quickly you know CRISPR
came out like 18 months ago and now
we're already talking about us you know
eliminating for example the mosquito I
mean that's a
a 750,000 deaths a year again we're
talking about a major humanitarian push
for a science that's about 18 months old
that's like unheard of you got major
views if you would have brought one of
those kits and you could add oh yeah
yeah not a little something